要は皆さんを情報学の世界にを誘うしようと思っています
4方角と聞いてどんなイメージを思い浮かべられるでしょうか
やいっぱいのスーパーコンピューターブンブンブン回して計算すると言うという
イメージを
たでしょうか
それもあの情報学の一つのイメージですけれども
どちらかというとそれはの計算をするというようなあの
重視そういう側面を重視したこれまで飲ま情報工学ですとか情報科学といった分野に
近いイメージだと思います
療法学というのはそういうこれまでの情報の考え方にさらに
人についての理解人がどうあるべきかとかそれから一の暮らす社会
そういったものについて情報を通して改めて取り組んでみようというのが大雑把に言え
ばそれが
情報学の考え方です
絵は情報とはどういったものでしょうか
ひょっと例を使ってみます
この皆さんがご覧になっている画像はこちらの中で大学の博物館にある人の王妃の木の
画像です
をものは博物館に展示をされていますけれどもこの画像と樹齢が950年
それから直径が2メーターですねすごく大きいんですけれどもそういう
[音楽]
このえっと表示を見て皆さんはその
まぁだいたいどんなものが展示されているのかを知ることができます
これが情報ですねえ
例えば他にも
行ってみると
この王妃の木の年輪は
平安時代の後期から昭和の初期までの時代をこう練りに刻んでいるとそういうあの事実
もすごく興味をそそられるかもしれない
やはり
対象そのものではなくて
対象についての表現あるいはその期日によって私たちは実際にそこにす存在しないもの
に関しても知ることができる
これが情報ですしこれがデジタル化されることで
世界中の人がこのな具
大学の博物館にある王妃納期のことを知ることができるわけですね
商品についても同じです例えば今だともうあの商店に行って商品を手に取らなくても皆
さんはインターネットで情報に基づいてあの注文されるわけですね
何こんな当たり前の事を言ってるんだっていう風に感じられると思うんですけれども
これは実は情報がこのぐらい私たちの生活にすごく浸透しているということです
所管の世界ではもうあの30年以上も前から
蔵書の情報というのが
標準的なやり方で記述されて
体系化されてそしてカタログという形で整理をされてきました
ですので世界中の図書館の蔵書は私たちが
検索をしてそのカタログに基づいてアクセスすることができるわけです
行ってみると世界中が仮想的に一つの図書館になった
そんなことが実現されているわけですねこれは図書館情報学という
発展に貢献をしたあ
あそんな風にその図書館の中とか博物館おこう歩き回って実際に歩かなくても仮想的な
高体験をするということは皆さんも聞きになったことがあるかもしれないです
これから多分その植物園にある花の香りたとか
売店にあるそのお菓子の味だとか実際のその経験実際の体験と仮想的な体験というのが
複雑に融合して夫複雑なその体験を得られるようになるかもしれない
あり
将来の世代の人たちは私たちの仮想体験によって実際の実体験というのが今よりもっと
基調でその贅沢な体験だという風に感じるかもしれないです
これだけ高仮想た空間の影響が私たちの価値観だとか
実体験に対して影響を与える可能性があると
ということを意味しています
どんな風にへ
阿蘇空間と実際のフィジカルな空間とが融合していて
へ
これから新たなその一択された世界というのが実現されると思います
サイバー空間での情報というのは実質関数的にものすごい距離でまあどうかしていると
言われていますし
皆さんが使うスマートフォンをあの変えられる行動情報何か新しい情報として
新たなその利活用の仕方それから新たなサービスですね
あなたの体験に結びつくということが日々起こっているわけです
こういうその
情報等体験が一体になることでこれからのその
私たちの世界というのが変わりつつあるということです
ここからちょっと情報学がどんな風に広がっているかということを感じてもらいたいと
思います
2003年にヒトゲノムプロジェクトヒトゲノム計画というのが完了して人間の中に
ヒトゲノムというあの池もの情報は an 10億ぐらいの延吉いいというあの形で
配列として配列の情報としてアクセスできるようになりました
でそこからあの人間にはだいたいその22005ぐらいの遺伝子があるというのは知見
が得られたり
これまで実験を通してが口にしていたようなことに対して情報使った仮説とか新たな
知見を組み合わせることであの人のメカニズムの解明ですとか荒れたり新しい医療とか
そういうところに大きな貢献をしました
を分野は生物情報学生命情報学という風に呼ばれています
こんな風にそのこれまで社会
hey
心理あるいは教育といった分野での蓄積されたあの知見というのが
情報学なアプローチによってそれを組み合わせることでどんどんと拡大して言ってい
ます
これまでのやり方に大量の情報蓄積してそれを分析したり
確保したり再利用するというような情報学のアプローチを使うことでこれまでとは違う
取り組み方を
あのにあのスタートできるそういうその情報学の拡大というのがすごい勢いで広がって
います
いってみれば今回のテレックス名古屋 u のテーマ
言いますと表邦楽の再起動ということになるかと思います
ではこれからの情報学というのはどこを目指していくのでしょうか
キーワードは価値創造ですたちを創造するというまあベタな表現ですけれども委員件と
いうのはこれまでに解けなかった問題へのソリューションだとか
今までに全くなかったような新しい体験ですね
利便性どういうものを高く評価をします
そういうその価値新しいその体験に対する価値というのが常方角によってもたらされる
というふうに考えています
例えばですね
心体的にの運転する能力注意力だとか
認知力が少しをとってきたと思った時にそれを補ってくれる運転支援の技術
あるいは人間を介在せずに運転してくれるような自動運転の技術ですねまぁこれも一つ
の例ですし個人のまあ遺伝子を含むような
本当に個人の特性に
も続いて健康指導をしたりあるいはその治療の方針を立てたりというパーソナル化され
た
医療こういったものが新しい価値の創造につながっているわけです
私はあの昨年の4月に名古屋大学にあの情報学研究科が新設されてそこにあの価値創造
研究センターもまさしく価値創造のための研究センターというところで普段
活動をしていますそこには3つのプロジェクトがありまして
革新的なものづくりですとか
人間と社会の幸福ウェルビーイング率だとかあるいはその持続可能な社会循環型の社会
に必要とされるような生物や物質情報を探求するテーマはあの様々なんですけれども
これは新しいすべて新しい情報学のアプローチということで
取り組みが行われています
たこに fedex いうな声で tx 名古屋 u であの遠くされた
氏原先生ですとか唐澤先生もあの
このプロジェクトで活躍されています
皆さんその過去のテレックス you love you のイベントをご覧になった
ことはありますか
なければこの機会にぜひあのをご覧になってください面白い話が満載ですので
私のあの専門の研究というのはあの人の使う言葉ですね主に書く言葉ですけど
言語の処理をあの研究しているそれが専門になります
皆さんあのマートスピーカーという言葉はあのご存知だと思うんですけどまぁこの会場
にもうあの持っているという方もたくさんいらっしゃるかもしれないんですけれども
スマートスピーカーの主な機能というのは音声をまああの処理するという部分とこの
対話を制御する対話をちゃんとコントロールしてあの対応を進行させる
というあの2つの大きな技術によって構成されていますけどこの対話技術というのも
あの言語処理の要素技術の一つ
えっとスマートスピーカーを使いやすくしようと思うとまぁいろんなことを言われても
ちゃんと対応できるようにしたいわけですけれども
例えばあのハリーポッターと賢者の石の作者は誰ですねあって聞かれたときにそれは
jk ローリングすですというふうにあの応えたいわけですね
人間同士の対応でしたら今6当たり前の簡単なことに思えるかもしれないんですけど
これをシステムにやらせようとするとりっ
頭はすごく難しい
なぜかと言いますとえ
ハリーポッターと賢者の石は小説と映画と量がありますよね
ここでそのちゃんと jk ローリングと答えるためにはこの質問の中の作者という
言葉が非常にあの融合に聞いて言ってこれを弾た後あの会社後しない限りあの映画館
映画のほうのハリーポッターと賢者の石のクリスコロンバスという g 名まで候補に
浮かんできますからそういう
ことちゃんと処理をするためにはかなり知的な計算が必要です
それはその質問を正しく分析して答えの嵐そうな情報源から答えの候補を出してきて
正解を正しく選ぶというのはいくつかの子を手順になりますけど
これはの質問オート技術という風に呼ばれています
こういった今でいうその人工知能のを支えるような技術
があの非常にこういった知的な対応に高瀬ないわけですね
これもたその情報が口の中でいう知能情報学的な分野になります
トリビアの問題についてはこういう問題を解けるシステムがたん登場していて2011
年にあのアメリカのテレビ番組で
あのチャンピオンと対戦をしてそのシステムがあの勝利をしたという事があのすごく
話題になったりしています
こういうその言語の処理をまあ追求していきますと私たちがその
へ
バッ
英語表現を通して知識をどういうふうに習得をしているのかあるいは世界をどんな風に
口を理解をしているのかというような
どういうメカニズムですね人間のその認知に関する
あのメカニズムを探求したいというような気持ちになるわけですね
a
私たちにとってはその人の知的な能力というのはものすごいミステリアスなものでそれ
をこう
少しずつ解きほぐしていこうというのが大きな研究者の動機になってい
こんな風にその人らしさ人のその知的な能力を解明していくと
[音楽]
これからの社会というのが大きく変わっていくと思います
私たちはその情報を元情報社会という形で社会世界を変えてきたわけですけどまだまだ
その世の中のシステムというのはある意味人工的であって
人が何らかの小不自由さを感じたりすごい興亜の負担を強いられるような経験をされる
かと思うんですけれどもこれから先の社会にはあの人のその判断ですとか人の振る舞い
というのをデータから学習することでどんどんその人のような振る舞いとか人はどう
いうふうに考えるんだろうということをデータを通して学習しようと
するわけですね
そうすれば今まで感じてた不自由さだとか変に高負担をかけるようなことが減っていっ
てどんどんその人と強調しやすいような社会になると思います
超スマート社会というのは呼ばれ方もしていますけど
いわばその社会が逃げ出したを学んでいく
そういうこの
社会的な変化というのが起こると思いますしこれがその
こういうあの変化を支えているのが情報学だということです
今日のこのあの話を聞きになって私もちょっと情報学の専門家になってみたいなとか
あれば自分なりの情報学を作ってみたいなというふうに思っていただける方が一人でも
出たらあの凄く嬉しいと思います
どうもありがとうございました